[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
today we're discussing the darker side
of the wizarding world what do you know
about the dark arts
just like any other line of magic the
spells and charms that the wizarding
community feared most the dark ants has
a long complex history but unfortunately
for modern historians much of it has
remained shrouded in secrecy
if it weren't for a few ancient dark
wizards like the sorcerer named god lo
who wrote the resource book magik
mostiville we would know very little of
the methods dark wizards employed in
their crafts but thanks to their texts
and the resurgence in dark magic the tom
riddle brought about towards the end of
the 20th century
were able to chart a course from the
earliest days of dark magic to the
modern era when we toss the term dark
arts around it's easy to think that
we're only talking about the three
unforgivable curses three spells that
would land a wizard or witch a one-way
ticket to a locked cell in
but the dark art was much more than just
a handful of curses that could kill or
torture their targets
dark magic just like normal magic ranged
from charms to potions to enchanted
objects although unlike the types of
magic that godric gryffindor and the
other hogwarts founders knew dark magic
could also include innately evil magical
beings like zombies vampires rugaru and
many more when we look at all the
various strains of dark magic that exist
it's tempting to think that the
distinction between normal magic the
type that first years would learn in a
typical class at hogwarts and the type
that a dark wizard like herpedophile
might use was just a small distinction
after all both types of magic used an
incredible amount of skill
and in their effect both types could
have an awfully powerful result
and that's actually a good point because
the very thing that makes dark magic
dark is the way it's used if someone
utilizes a spell potion or charm to harm
someone whether physically or mentally
then it is typically considered dark
magic
in addition to that if a spell potion or
creature was created explicitly through
dark means then it too by default is
considered dark magic but just because a
wizard used dark magic it didn't
suddenly make them a dark wizard in the
united kingdom the ministry of magic
would often give its auras and officers
authority to use dark magic whenever
situations demanded it
during war even the unforgivable curses
the three spells that would land wizards
life sentences in prison could be
utilized if the ministry agreed and that
was just in the nations that comprise
the uk
in other parts of the world the
wizarding community had even more
flexible positions on the use of dark
magic
most famously former death eater igor
kakarov allowed students to enroll in an
outright dark arts class at his school
the dermstrang institute the most famous
exception to the common misconception
that only dark wizards used dark magic
was perhaps severus snape's use of the
killing curse as part of a long-running
ruse to deceive lord voldemort snape and
dumbledore both decided that severus
would have to kill the aging wizard when
the opportunity arose although severus
had once been a death eater by the time
he pointed his wandered albus and took
his dear friend's life he had been
completely redeemed this instance was
further proof that simple honest good
wizards or grey and snape's case were
also capable of utilizing the dark arts
without damaging their souls when we
turn our attention to the historical
texts stashed in madame irma pince's
library we sadly find that many of the
books on the dark arts are locked behind
cabinets in the restricted section but
even if you were lucky enough to gain
access you'd discover that the history
of dark wizards and their magic seems to
begin sometime around 100 bce
far later than muggles started recording
their own history
although it's tempting to think that
most of the ancient law of the dark
wizards was deliberately destroyed
through the ages there's probably a far
simpler explanation most of mughal's own
recorded history failed to survive the
centuries of war famine and natural
disasters that struck europe over the
past three millennia and with the
magical community comprising a far
smaller segment of the population and
the dark arts practitioners representing
an even smaller fraction it's only
natural that only a few documents
endured but thanks to these ancient
tales like the ones of herper the foul
and heroid and owner of the elder wand
were able to piece the story together by
the time voldemort came to power much of
what was known of the dark arts had
already been established by the dark
wizards that preceded him although his
own master of the creation of horcruxes
and complex potions made him seem like a
dark wizard on the cutting edge of
magical breakthroughs he was pretty
mundane with his use of techniques when
it comes to dark magic in general there
are typically two types that wizards
employ
charms and potions
if we start with charms first we can
break that down into three further
categories ranked from weakest to
strongest these were jinxers hexes and
curses jinxers as we've already
suggested were the weakest types of
charms that a dark wizard could utilize
among the many jinxers the knockback
jinx is probably the best example
in the dark forces a guide to
self-protection the knockback jinx is a
simple technique that wizards used while
battling each other to push their
opponents backwards professor mcgonagall
once used it during her early years as
an instructor at hogwarts and it was a
fairly typical spell for novices
when we take a step up and look at hexes
we'll see that these are considerably
crueler and more devastating than the
comparatively weak jinxers
amongst the most terrible hexes there
was the illegal growth hex which would
cause a victim's head to grow
uncontrollably the pus squirting hex
which caused painful red boils to bubble
to a wizard's skin and spew rivers of
white pass
and the horn tongue hex which
transformed the victim's tongue into a
painful horn now the final category for
dark arts charms is the curse
these were the most powerful and damning
spells that wizards could produce
among these charms the three
unforgivable curses were the most
terrifying as we mentioned earlier if
any wizard ever used these particular
spells on another they would be
condemned to a life sentence in azkaban
prison
the killing curse which you already know
is the most feared of the three
but the cruciatus curse a spell that
causes a victim to feel unbelievable
amounts of pain was perhaps far worse
the imperious curse the last of the
three may seem more innocent but it
isn't if a dark wizard used this spell
on you then you'd be forced to do
whatever they bid however it should be
important to remember that there are
other dark curses like the entrail
expelling curse that should also
probably be given unforgivable status
beyond curses the dark ants are most
often applied to potions the drink of
despair the emerald potion that was used
to protect salazar the rinse locket one
of lord voldemort's most difficult
horcruxes to retrieve was an example of
just how terrible a dark potion could be
the only way to dispose of the potion
was to drink it and the effects were
horrible
even the most powerful wizard of his age
albus dumbledore was unable to overcome
the effects of the drink of despair as
he struggled to consume it all
this in fact was one of the many
inventions that lord voldemort claimed
to have achieved in his many years of
studying the dark arts besides the drink
of despair other famous dark potions
relied on terrible ingredients like
unicorn blood in order to bring their
desired results but if a dark wizard was
willing to go to such terrible depths he
could create a new body for himself like
voldemort ultimately did using these
spells and potions a wizard could
enchant objects with harmful intentions
like the hogwarts founders enchanted the
sorting hat in order to select students
for their houses in the years after
their deaths dark wizards used similar
techniques to curse pens books and even
houses but the topic of dark creatures
is perhaps the most interesting of all
the dark ants while some like the
basilisk were the result of
experimentation conducted by dark
wizards many of these beasts occurred
naturally in the wild bogats and
dementors are the most famous but
vampires banshees and hags plagued
wizards for centuries as well the fact
that many of these beasts preyed on
witches and wizards wasn't the only
reason they were considered dark
many other beasts like dragons and
manticores were known to eat people but
were often unlisted in catalogues of
dark creatures it seemed to most that a
certain level of sentience and a
deliberate desire to be cruel were the
attributes that separated dark creatures
from other predators when we take a step
back and look at all that the dark art
comprises it's hard not to feel a sense
of awe
and when we consider the ultimate legacy
of dark magic you might find that you
feel an equally large sense of terror as
we said earlier not all dark arts
practitioners were evil but the
overwhelming majority were and to the
lives they ruined and the devastation
they brought on the wizarding community
would leave scars for centuries to come
and that's it for this video if you
enjoyed the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember the mind is not
a book to be opened at will and examined
at leisure